Блокпости, озброєні поліцейські та нацгвардійці.
Це не охоплений війною Донбас, а Західна Україна.
І тут теж триває боротьба. Бурштинова.
Три роки тому ситуацію почали відстежувати
спостерігачі спеціальної місії ОБСЄ.
Колишній військовий, 55-річний чех Іван Дудак
рацює в складі місії з початку її діяльності - березня 2014-го.
Рік він провів в окупованому Донецьку. З середини 2015-ого
відвідує проблемні регіони в Західній Україні.
Уявіть собі, три роки тому тут було повно нелегальних дигерів.
Це одне з великих родовищ бурштину.
У вересні2015-ого року
в цей ліс в Маневицькому районі на Волиніприйшли тисячі копачів,
дізнавшись про велике родовище бурштину
на глибині усього один метр.
Тоді спостерігачі ОБСЄ повідомляли про ескалацію конфлікту.
Після того ліс взяли під контроль правоохоронці.
ОБСЄ продовжує моніторинг,
адже видобуток бурштину
тут законодавчо поки не врегульований.
Не було спроб з боку копателів знов почати видобуток?
З вересня 15-ого року не було.
Ви охороняєте цю територію 24 години на добу 7 днів на тиждень?
Про це Іван Дудак питатиме і місцевих жителів, і чиновників.
Якщо виявить розбіжності,
обов’язково напише про це у звіті.
Іван Дудак один з майже 60 спостерігачів,
які працюють в Західній Україні.
В них чимало роботи - патрулюють щодня.
Останнім часом їх непокоять акти вандалізму,
на українських та польських кладовищах.
Це монумент польським солдатам,
які загинули під час Першої світової війни.
Ми спостерігаємо за цим місцем згідно з нашим мандатом про моніторинг
відносин між меншинами, наявності напруги чи вандалізму.
Колега Івана 28-річна Алтинай Мирзабекова з Киргизстану
розповідає, що спостерігачі майже завжди виїжджають туди,
де виникають конфлікти на релігійному чи національному ґрунті.
Вони не мають права втручатися в ситуацію.
Але часто їхня  присутність
допомагає знизити соціальну напругу, каже спостерігачка.
В березні цього року наші колеги в Івано-Франківську
оперативно відреагували на повідомлення
про напади на членів угорської меншини на Закарпатті,
відправивши патруль у регіон, встановивши важливі факти.
Таким чином вони мінімізували простір для спекуляцій.
Діалог - інструмент ОБСЄ для вирішення будь-якого конфлікту.
Спостерігачі інвестують багато часу
у спілкування з  громадянами та владою.
На їхні звіти про порушення прав людини
чи небезпечні ситуації влада, зазвичай, реагує,
каже Володимир Онофрійчук -
голова Костюхнівської сільради, яка в 2015-ому році
змогла вирішити проблему з нелегальними копателями бурштину
лише після втручання районної та обласної держадміністрацій,
уряду, Нацполіції та Нацгвардії.
Перевіряти, перепровіряти, як тут робиться,
як йдуть реформи, в якій стадії , на якому вони етапі….
І, мабуть, від того оцінка робиться
і в Європі про Україну...
Звіти про моніторинг ОБСЄ призначені
для усіх 57-ми країн – членів організації,
які надають Україні, зокрема, фінансову допомогу.
Із них міжнародні партнери роблять висновки про проблеми в державі,
дотримання прав людини чи, наприклад, стан реформ.